Now, we're ready to actually
start building models.
So as usual, the first
thing we're going to do
is split our data into a
training and a testing set.
And for this problem,
we're actually
going to train on data from
the 2004 and 2008 elections,
and we're going to test
on data from the 2012
presidential election.
So to do that, we'll
create a data frame
called Train, using the subset
function that breaks down
the original polling
data frame and only
stores the observations when
either the Year was 2004
or when the Year was 2008.
And to obtain the
testing set, we're
going to use subset to create
a data frame called Test that
saves the observations
in polling where
the year was 2012.
So now that we've broken it down
into a training and a testing
set, we want to understand
the prediction of our baseline
model against which
we want to compare
a later logistic
regression model.
So to do that, we'll
look at the breakdown
of the dependent
variable in the training
set using the table function.
What we can see here is that
in 47 of the 100 training
observations, the
Democrat won the state,
and in 53 of the observations,
the Republican won the state.
So our simple baseline
model is always
going to predict the more
common outcome, which
is that the Republican is
going to win the state.
And we see that the
simple baseline model
will have accuracy of
53% on the training set.
Now, unfortunately, this
is a pretty weak model.
It always predicts Republican,
even for a very landslide
Democratic state, where
the Democrat was polling
by 15% or 20% ahead
of the Republican.
So nobody would really consider
this to be a credible model.
So we need to think of a smarter
baseline model against which
we can compare our logistic
regression models that we're
going to develop later.
So a reasonable
smart baseline would
be to just take one of
the polls-- in our case,
we'll take Rasmussen--
and make a prediction
based on who poll said
was winning in the state.
So for instance, if the
Republican is polling ahead,
the Rasmussen smart
baseline would just
pick the Republican
to be the winner.
If the Democrat was ahead,
it would pick the Democrat.
And if they were tied,
the model would not
know which one to select.
So to compute this
smart baseline,
we're going to use a new
function called the sign
function.
And what this function
does is, if it's
passed a positive number,
it returns the value 1.
If it's passed a negative
number, it returns negative 1.
And if it's passed
0, it returns 0.
So if we passed the
Rasmussen variable into sign,
whenever the Republican was
winning the state, meaning
Rasmussen is positive,
it's going to return a 1.
So for instance,
if the value 20 is
passed, meaning the Republican
is polling 20 ahead,
it returns 1.
So 1 signifies that the
Republican is predicted to win.
If the Democrat is leading
in the Rasmussen poll,
it'll take on a negative value.
So if we took for instance
the sign of -10, we get -1.
So -1 means this
smart baseline is
predicting that the
Democrat won the state.
And finally, if we
took the sign of 0,
meaning that the
Rasmussen poll had a tie,
it returns 0, saying
that the model is
inconclusive about who's
going to win the state.
So now, we're ready
to actually compute
this prediction for all
of our training set.
And we can take a
look at the breakdown
of that using the
table function applied
to the sign of the training
set's Rasmussen variable.
And what we can see is that
in 56 of the 100 training set
observations, the smart
baseline predicted
that the Republican
was going to win.
In 42 instances, it
predicted the Democrat.
And in two instances,
it was inconclusive.
So what we really want to do
is to see the breakdown of how
the smart baseline model does,
compared to the actual result
-- who actually won the state.
So we want to again
use the table function,
but this time, we want to
compare the training set's
outcome against the sign
of the polling data.
So in this table, the rows
are the true outcome --
1 is for Republican,
0 is for Democrat --
and the columns are the smart
baseline predictions, -1, 0,
or 1.
What we can see is in the
top left corner over here,
we have 42 observations where
the Rasmussen smart baseline
predicted the
Democrat would win,
and the Democrat
actually did win.
There were 52 observations where
the smart baseline predicted
the Republican would win,
and the Republican actually
did win.
Again, there were those two
inconclusive observations.
And finally, there
were four mistakes.
There were four times where the
smart baseline model predicted
that the Republican would
win, but actually the Democrat
won the state.
So as we can see, this
model, with four mistakes
and two inconclusive results
out of the 100 training
set observations is doing much,
much better than the naive
baseline, which simply
was always predicting
the Republican
would win and made
47 mistakes on the same data.
So we see that this is a much
more reasonable baseline model
to carry forward, against
which we can compare
our logistic
regression-based approach.